in this segment we develop some
consequences of the independence
assumption that we have made on the
trials that constitute a Bernoulli
process these properties will be pretty
intuitive but they play an important
role they're helpful in solving problems
and they're also quite helpful in
understanding the continuous time
version of the Bernoulli process namely
the Poisson process that we will be
studying later so here's the story we
start with a Bernoulli process with some
parameter P the process starts a friend
of yours
watches the process and they observe the
results of the different trials let's
say for five time steps and at this time
right after time five they call you into
the room and you start watching the rest
of the process what will you see
the first random variable that you will
see is the result of whatever happens in
this time slot which is the sixth slot
of the original process the second
random variable that you will see is the
result of the seventh random variable in
the original process and so on so the
process that you get to see is the
process who why I wear eye ranges over
the non-negative integers what
properties does this process have
because of the assumption that the
different trials are independent this
means that the first five trials are
independent from the trials that happen
after time five so one property is that
the process Y I is independent of
whatever happens in the past which is x1
up to X 5 second the random variables
that you see X 6 X 7 and so on are
independent Bernoulli random variables
with parameter P so the random variables
Y I
constitutes also a Bernoulli process
with parameter P so the process that you
get to see which is the sequence of
trials after time v is identical
probabilistically to a Bernoulli process
with parameter P like the process X I so
it's as if a Bernoulli process was just
starting fresh at this particular time
and because of this we say that the
process has a fresh start property after
a certain time in this example we used
five as the certain time but instead of
five we could have any particular
integer little and in which case our
process y one starts with X n plus one
continues with X and plus two and so on
and here instead of X 5 we would have
written X n so after a deterministic
time end what you see is the same as if
we had the Bernoulli process that was
starting fresh at this particular time
and which is also independent from
whatever happened in the past
let us now complicate the story a little
bit suppose that your friend watches the
Bernoulli process and they keep watching
it until a success is observed for the
first time right at that time they call
you into the row and you start watching
the rest of the process this is the
length of time that we have called t1
the number of trials until the first
success so what is it that you will be
watching the first random variable that
you will see is what happens in slot t1
plus 1 the second random variable that
you will see is what happened in slot t1
plus 2 and so on and this defines again
a process the sequence of the Y's this
is what you will see starting from
this particular time what kind of
process is it
well these trials happened in the past
we know what they were but no matter
what they wear the future trials will
still be independent and independent of
the past and each one of the trials will
have probability P of being a success so
the properties that we have again is
that the trials that you see are
independent of the past which in this
case is everything from X 1 up to time X
t1 and what you see is a Bernoulli
process we describe the situation by
saying that the process starts fresh
after time t1 and by this again we mean
that if you start watching the process
right after t1 what you will see will be
a Bernoulli process which is independent
from whatever happened in the past
having just argued that the process
starts fresh at the time t1 of the first
success we can now ask whether such a
property is also true more generally
that is if we start watching the process
at some random time n will the process
start fresh at that time let us look at
some additional examples suppose that
capital n is the time of the third
success so your friend who watches the
Bernoulli process and each time they say
did the third success occur not yet not
yet not yet not yet yes
the third success just occurred and at
that time they called you into the room
and you start watching what happens from
that time on what will you be seeing
after that time there will be
independent Bernoulli trials that take
place and these refer to the future of
the process looking
from this particular point in time and
the future is independent from whatever
happened in the past so what you
actually see is indeed a fresh Bernoulli
process that starts here and which is
independent from the random variables
that occurred in the past
let us look at another example let
capital n be the first time that three
successes in a row have been recorded so
your friend again watches the process
and they ask each time did we see three
successes in a row not yet not yet not
yet not yet not yet yes I just saw three
successes in a row and now your friend
calls you in and you start watching the
process from this point in time by the
same argument as before whatever happens
in the future is going to be Bernoulli
trials that are independent from the
past so you will again have a fresh
start property starting from this time
so in both cases formally what we have
is that the process that you get to
observe starting after time capital n
after the time that you are called to
and asked to start watching what you
will see is going to be a sequence of
independent Bernoulli trials that is a
Bernoulli process and this sequence of
future trials is independent from
whatever happened in the past of the
process what both of these examples have
in common is that the random variable
end the time at which you're called in
is causally determined from the history
of the process what does that mean it
means that somebody is watching the
process and at each point in time based
on what they have seen so far they
decide whether to call you in or not
what could be an example of a non-causal
time and here it is n could be the time
just before the first
currents of 1 1 1 so in this example
here you would be called into the room
and start watching at this time so your
friend somehow knows that a sequence of
1 1 1 is going to occur and called you
just before it happens how could that be
well imagine that the Bernoulli process
actually was run yesterday it was
recorded in a movie your friend has seen
the movie so knows everything that's
going to happen and so when the movies
replayed today your friend can call you
in at this time and tell you you know
something very interesting is about to
happen come in and start watching now
what will you be watching what you will
watch will be 1 1 1 with certainty you
are certain that the first 3 trials that
you will see will be once and well the
subsequent ones will be random but since
you know that the first 3 trials will be
1 this means that statistically they're
not described by the statistics of a
Bernoulli process in a Bernoulli process
each trial has a probability of being 1
and the probability of being 0 but since
in your case you're certain to watch
once in the beginning this means that
the random variables that you see do not
conform to the description of a
Bernoulli process so this is an example
in which n is not causally determined
and in this example you do not get to
see a Bernoulli process we do not have
the fresh start property what happened
here is more generally true we do have a
fresh start property but not always we
have it under the assumption that the
time at which you are asked to start
watching is determined from the past
history of the process in some causal
manner this is a general fact that can
be established rigorously
however we will not go through a formal
mathematical derivation the formal
argument for the most general case
involves somewhat tedious symbol
manipulations that do not provide any
additional insights
however the intuition behind this result
should be fairly clear and we will use
it freely whenever we need it